[Musik]
was denkst du denn ich weiß es nicht
eigentlich muss ich glücklich sein wir
können jetzt in deutschland bleiben aber
das ist nicht deine heimat doch das ist
eine andere eine neue heimat
ich finde deutschland schön aber
deutschland ist anders ist die alte
heimat syrien oder ja das essen ist
anders das wetter die sprache und die
menschen auch alles ist anders hat die
in syrien den auf frühling sommer herbst
und winter wie in deutschland
wir haben auch jahreszeiten aber im
winter ist es nicht so kalt
und das essen wir essen viel fleisch bei
uns gibt es nicht viele vegetarier aber
vor allem gibt es in syrien nicht so
viele regeln wie in deutschland
es gibt viel mehr leben auf der straße
besonders am abend
die läden sind länger geöffnet die
menschen sind draußen alles ist ein
bisschen spontaner und lockerer ja
eigentlich ist fast alles anders
aber ich finde die menschen die in
deutschland sind genauso nett wie die
menschen in syrien